[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
joining us today is sean stick's larkin
retired tulsa police sergeant and host
of the podcast cocktails
along with terry austin shot back and
forth from state to federal courts
what do you imagine transporting an
officer convicted of murder like this
is like you know it's going to be
uncomfortable for
the officers the deputies the marshals
everybody involved
i myself was involved in an arrest here
in tulsa several years ago
we actually had to arrest an officer on
duty and just that
alone is so uncomfortable you know
chauvin is
in a negative way i guess probably the
most well-known police officer in the
country at least right now
and so for everybody involved in that
transportation they understand that they
are going to be under scrutiny they're
going to be watched
it's going to be on the cameras and it's
just going through the motion for these
guys
you know let's hope they're definitely
safe and no one's targeting them there
don't want that to happen of course
terry eric nelson does know a lot about
the case
but could it be better to have a i don't
know another pair of eyes on this case
as we go to another step in the trial
listen i would want someone who knows
the case inside and out but in a perfect
world you know a defendant would have
someone who knows the case plus someone
who has a fresh pair of eyes
but a right to a fair trial definitely
does not include unlimited funding for
representation
now and jeanette we do provide criminal
defense
for individuals if they can't afford it
myself being a public defender
but do you know how much defending a
case like this could cost in federal
court
you know i asked around and say that
derek chovin
had unlimited funds and he could pay for
a lawyer
i talked to jay clark about this for
instance and he said that this defense
in federal court would cost at least six
figures he
guessed that a retainer alone would be
250 thousand dollars and he said well
think about it
even if it was a hundred thousand
dollars that's still a lot of money for
somebody to come up with
so it would be incredibly expensive he
said just because of the amount of work
that goes into it and the high profile
nature of the case
that of course would be for someone to
retain if there's a defense attorney
maybe probably
much less i know that cja or the federal
panel pays about 150
190 depending on if it's capital or
non-capital so we'll keep eyes on that
now don't go anywhere sean because i
know you have a new book coming out
about your experience as a law
enforcement officer breaking blue tells
real stories of cops accused of
wrongdoing
and subsequently cleared lark even
shares his own story
breaking blue will be released on june
15th and is available for pre-order now
sticks i've got ass let's get right to
it tell us about when you were
wrongfully accused
oh well unfortunately there's several
different incidents some small in size
some much larger but the one i focus on
here in the books started in 2009
there was a federal investigation of
tulsa police department for a couple
different groups of officers
and this thing just in my opinion it
steamrolled and and got out of control
pretty soon you had bad guys that were
essentially being told by
by the fbi um that was in doing the
investigation that hey if you've got
information on dirty cops we can help
you out with one of your
we can help you out with your case if
they were already locked up hey we can
get you out of jail then people started
filing civil lawsuits
and it just started building up over a
year time period and
there were a handful different officers
whose names got brought up
um some in fact did get arrested and go
to trial luckily for myself i did not
but i was labeled as what they call an
unindicted co-conspirator
um and still something still to this day
that if you google my name it
occasionally pop
up and throughout my career i've had to
deal with that title and uh fighting it
every step of the way in court
well let me put this one way uh sean i
would say it's not
unlucky or luck it's innocence it's
obviously there's a reason why you
weren't arrested for that now in this
collection of stories is there one from
someone else
that stuck out to you even now as you
think back on your book
yeah absolutely you know i was fortunate
to talk with several different officers
across the country and these things
range from a simple traffic stop
to you know a guy who spent time in
prison for a murder he didn't commit
but one of them was a guy by the name of
clyde ray spencer it actually took place
in the 1980s
he was arrested and convicted for child
molestation of his own kids when they
were very very little
and he spent a little over 20 years in
prison and over that time it finally
came out
that the his ex-wife was having a sexual
affair with the supervisor over the
investigating unit
dna evidence or what we call a sane exam
a sexual assault exam
uh that was never turned in it was held
in a detective's garage for nearly 20
years
and later magically appeared that would
have cleared him probably during trial
um so this poor guy spent you know i
think was a total like 21 years
in prison for a crime he never committed
thank you for that sean make sure to
check out sean larkin's book which is
available now for pre-order
but of course is coming out on june 15th
still ahead on law and crime daily we
take you inside the courtroom of two
live trials we're following
gabriel gavin but first a sneak peek
into the latest show featuring
defendants taking the stand
our interview with dan abrams after the
break
you